[موسيقى]
طبتم وطابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
التاسعه هذا المساء نبداها بابرز العناوين
تقارير عن اتفاق الايراني الروسي لبناء
مصنع للمسيرات في روسيا وانتاج 6000 مسيره
للحرب في اوكرانيا
على خلفيه ازمه المنطاد الصيني وزير النقل
الامريكي لا يستبعد فرض عقوبات على بكين
وفيران الاصلاحيون يعبرون عن ياسهم من
النظام الحالي ويدعون لتغييرات عاجله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من هذا الخبر الذي
اوردته صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال بان روسيا
وايران تمضيان قدما في خطتهما لبناء مصنع
جديد في روسيا يمكن ان يصنع مال يقل عن
سته الاف طائره مسيره ايرانيه التصميم
للحرب في اوكرانيا وقال مسؤولون للصحيفه
ان وفد ايراني الرفيع المستوى سافر الى
روسيا في اوائل يناير لزياره الموقع
المخطط للمصنعي والتوصل الى تفاصيل بدء
المشروع وتشغيله
وفي كيف تعهد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
والاكسيه بعدم استهداف روسيا بالصواريخ
طويله المدى مؤكدا انهم سيضربون فقط
الوحدات الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تعهد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ياتي بعد ان
اكدت الولايات المتحده في وقت سابق ان
صاروخ جديدا بعيدا المدى يمكنه ان يضاعف
مدى الهجمات الاوكرانيه مدرج ضمن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه جديده
كان هذا ميدانيا اما في ملفات الفساد التي
تواجهها اوكرانيا داخليا فقد دخل وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
انه لن يستقيل الا اذا اتخذ الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي هذا القرار مؤكدا ان
التحقيقات في قضايا الفساد بالوزاره
تصريحاته تاتي بعدما ترددت انباء عن قرب
تغييرات محتمله في السلطه الاوكرانيه
ستطال وزير الدفاع وفق مصادر برلمانيه
اوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
ازمه منطقه تشهدها العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه مؤخرا على خلفيه بالون صيني فجرته
الدفاع على الامريكيه في اجوائها وقالت
واشنطن انه منطادو تجسس لكن رفضت الاتهام
الامريكي كما اقالتها سلطات الصينيه رئيسه
هيئه الارصاد الجويه في البلاد وحملته
مسؤوليه انحراف المنطاد الى الولايات
المتحده فيما اعلن وزير النقل الامريكي ان
واشنطن قد تفرض عقوبات على بكين بسبب
المنطاد الصيني معتبرا ان بلاده اوضحت ان
ما جرى هو انتهاك غير مقبول لسياده
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
تجسس صينيه وهو الذي شغل الولايات المتحده
والعالم سقط بصاروخ واحد وبامر رئاسي بعد
ان تجول لايام في الاجواء الامريكيه هذا
المنطاد بدا مساره فوق جزر الاسكا توما
اتجه نحو كندا ليحلق بعيدا ويدخل المجال
الجوي الامريكي فوق ولايه مونتانا في
الحادي والثلاثين من يناير الاسبوع الماضي
المنطاد عاده هو عباره عن سفينه هوائيه
تملا بغاز اله او الهيليوم يمكن ان يرتفع
في الجو دون دفع او دون جهاز دفع يحمل
باسفله جهاز تجسس او غيره حسب طبيعه هذه
المهمه التي يقوم بها هذا المنطاد اما
المنطاد الصيني الذي تم رصده في الاجواء
الامريكيه فهيصعب اسقاطه من مضادات
الطائرات لان معظم انظمه الاسلحه المضاده
للطائرات الامريكيه لم تكن مصممه للقضاء
على الاهداف المرتفعه ولاجل ذلك لجات
واشنطن لاسقاط
هذا
او الاسقاط هذا المنطاد بالطائره طائره
مقاتله من طراز اف 22 اطلقت عليه صاروخا
واحدا من نوع ام
9 اكس هذا الصاروخ هو صاروخ جوجو قصير
المدى كمان نشاهد
تصل كلفته الى 400 الف دولار دخل الخدمه
في البحريه الامريكيه عام
1956 واستخدمته القوات الجويه عام
1964 الجيش الامريكي
يعمل حاليا على استعاده حموله هذا المنطاد
الذي اسقطته على بعد سته اميال بحريه
قباله السواحل الولايات المتحده وعلى عمقه
47 قدما وهو ما يسهل من عمليه جمعه عبر
غواصين ومركبه غير ماهوله لانتشال جسم هذا
البالون ورفعه الى السطح الى سفينه
الانتشار بهدف التحقيق فيماهيه مهمه
المنطاد الصيني
والجزم وفق هذا وفق شبكه سي ان ان عن
طبيعه هذا المنطاد
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من واشنطن حسين طوده مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك حسين يعني حسين الان نريد
معرفه الجديد ميدانيا حول هذا المنطاد
الذي اسقط وكذلك سياسيا في واشنطن
تحيه لك عادل ميدانيه طبعا عمليه
انتشال حطام هذا المنطاد مستمره هي بدات
البارحة بعد اسقاطه قباله سواحل
كما ذكرت في الخبر
طبعا هناك تحديات جديده لا يتحدثون عنها
في الاعلام الامريكي تتعلق
بحاله هذا الحطام عندما اصطدم في المياه
لانه هبط بسرعه وايضا موضوع تسرب المياه
الى معداته قد يؤثر عليها وقد يتلفها بسبب
ملوحه هذه المياه عمليه الانتشار لم تحدد
الوقت الزمني لهذه العمليه لم يحددها
المسؤولون الامريكيون لكنهم قالوا
انها ستكون عمليه سهله لتكون الحطام موجود
الان على عمق 47 قدما تحت سطح مياه البحر
بعد انتشار هذا الحطام البارحه حسب ما
فهمنا انتشر جزء منه ولكن سيتم اخذه الى
مختبر كوانتيكو هنا فرجينيا حيث هذا
المختبر حيث سيتم فحص هذا الحطام لمعرفه
ماهيه المعلومات التي حصل عليها وماهيه
الصور التي صورها خاصه انه كما نعرف مره
فوق ولايه مونتانا في الشمال الولايات
المتحده وهي ولايه تضم عدد من المنشات
النوويه والقواعد العسكريه المهمه واستمر
بالهبوط وثم تحول شرقا سياسيا وسط
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى انتهى بها
المطاف فوق
سياسيا
يتواصل هجوم الجمهوريين على اداره الرئيس
بايدن بسبب تاخرها باسقاط هذا المنطاد
اليوم كان هناك بيان لكبير الجمهوريين في
مجلس الشيوخ قال ان رد الرئيس بايدن تاخر
الرئيس بايدن باسقاط هذا المنطاد غير حاسم
وانه اضاع فرصه لحمايه سياده الولايات
المتحده وليرسل بالرساله قوه ورساله ردع
حازمه لكل من تسول له نفسه كما اذا صح
التعبير من اجل اختراق الاجواء الولايات
في نفس السياق تحدث ايضا كبير الجمهوريين
في لجنه لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس الشيوخ
السيناتور الجمهوري ماركوروبيو اعتبر بان
جاء متاخرا وايضا قارنه هذا التاخر هو
بدايه تاخر في
او تقصير في اداء الواجب لكنه اشار لنقطه
مهمه حسب روبيو بان الصين ارادت من هذا
البالون ان تختبر قوه وعزم الولايات
المتحده وترسل بالرساله الى دول المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ تفيد بان الولايات المتحده
التي لم تستطع ان تفعل شيء لهذا المنطاد
الايام وهو يحلق في اجوائها فكيف تتوقعون
منها ان تاتي لمساعدتكم اذا ارادت الصين
تتحرك في هذه الدول شكرا جزيلا لحسين
الطود مراسل العربيه من واشنطن
هذه النشره المستمره وتتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
عبر العربيه حزب الحريه الكردستاني
الايراني يطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي بعدم
التردد في تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
الى ايران حيث المواجهه التي يخوضها
الاصلاحيون ضد النظام الحالي اذ حظ الرئيس
الايراني السابق محمد خاتمي ورئيس الوزراء
الايراني السابق مير حسين موسوي على اجراء
تغيير في النظام السياسي في البلاد وفي
قرار كان اشبه باعتراف بانتاج التعنيف
والاعتقالات بحق المتظاهرين في الفتره
الاخيره اصدر القضاء الايراني قرارا
بالافراج عن الاف المعتقلين على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره لكن حتى هذا الافراج
كان مشروطا اذ ان المعتقلين اجبروا على
التوقيع على تعهد الشعور بالندم قبل اطلاق
سراحهم بدورها اعتبرت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ان العفو الذي اصدره خامنئي
عفوا كاذب
[موسيقى]
هذا وبعد وقت قصير من اعلان الافراج عن
الاف المعتقلين على خلفيه الاحتجاجات في
ايران افدت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه بان
السلطات اعتقلت الصحفيه النازي محمد والتي
تعمل في احدى المؤسسات الاعلاميه التابعه
للاصلاحيين دون توضيح سبب الاعتقال علما
ان الناس المعتقل هي شقيقه الصحفيه الهي
محمد المعتقل على خلفيه نشرها خبر وفاه
الفتاه الكرديه مهسه اميني التي تسبب
مقتلها باحتجاجات كبيره شامله معظم ايران
وعلى اثرها وجه النظام تهمه الدعايه ضد
ايران والتامر ضد الامن القومي كما اصدر
القضاء عقوبه السجن سنه واحده بحق الصحفي
حسين يزدي الموقوف في اصفهان لتصل قائمه
الصحفيين المعتقلين على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
في ايران الى ثلاثين صحفيا
[موسيقى]
في ايران ايضا وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه
طالب رئيس حزب الحريه الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض طلب الاتحاد الاوروبي بعدم التردد
وتصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني منظمه
ارهابيه وانتقد في الوقت ذاته تردد الغربي
بهذا الشان
في الواقع سقطت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
بالفعل في اذهان الناس ما ابقى الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه هو العلاقات مع اوروبا والموقف
الضعيف للولايات المتحده ومع ذلك هذا
يتغير لقد غيرت الولايات المتحده موقفها
ولا تريد الدخول في مفاوضات مع ايران ايضا
غير الاوروبيون مواقفهم لان ايران لم تعد
تمتلك ربحا اقتصاديا لاوروبيين وقد ثار
الشعب على النظام نرحب بتصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه لقد تاخرت
كثيرا لكن هذا افضل من عدمه في الوقت نفسه
نشعر ببعض الشك بين الدول الاوروبيه نامل
ان يكونوا واثقين من قرارهم نامل ان يقوم
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاوروبيه بتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
قلى عضو مجلس السياده السودانيه الفريق
اول ركن شمس الدين كباشي في زيارته لولايه
جنوب كردفان قال ان القوى الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي ليست كافيه لتحقيق
الاستقرار في السودان احنا بنقول
احنا
معقول لتحقيق الاستقرار السياسي
والاستقرار في كافه لانه الامن وعلى
الاقتصاد وغيره وغير
انه احنا ندعو كل الاخوه
الموقعين على الاتفاق الاداري انه يفتح
صدورهم ويقبلوا الاخرين
صحيح ما ممكن ما كل الناس حتجي
لكن بيبقى برضو اتفاق متوافق عليه
وبيتدرجه مقبوله من الناس لانه ما في
توافق
تحول السلطات في كوريا الشماليه نشر مقاطع
على موقع يوتيوب عبر مؤثرين محللين في
محاوله لعكس نظره النمطيه عنها واقناع
السياح بان البلاد امنه المزيد في التقرير
التالي
نزهات ضحكات جولات سياحيه واقع وردي تحاول
كوريا الشماليه عكسه عن طبيعه الحياه فيها
من خلال صفحات مؤثرين محليين فما يعرفه
العالم عم يوجانغ هو عزلتها عن العالم
الخارجي وعداوتها مع جارتها الجنوبيه
والغرب والقليل عن حياه سكانها يعرض هؤلاء
المؤثرون عبر منصاتهم لقطات يقال بانها
جزء من اسلوب حياه طبيعيه يعيشه المواطن
في كوريا الشماليه
سينما مسابح مسارح متنزهات ترفيهيه وامور
اخرى قد تكون من المسلمات في اي بلد اخر
لكن ليس وفق ما تعرف عنه حول واقع حيث
الكماليات تعد رفاهيه لفئات محدده
الخبراء يرون بان تلك المقاطع ما هي الا
محاوله تظليليه من قبل السلطات في كوريا
الشماليه بهدف الدفع بالبلد المعزول
الاجتماعيا واقتصاديا وسياسيا وتصويره
كبلد امن للسياح
تحاول كوريا الشماليه تغيير الصوره
النمطيه عنها استغلال حملات دعائيه يقول
محللون بانها وهميه ولا تعكس حقيقه ما
يعانيه الكوريون الشماليون من تضييق وحذر
على تسريب المعلومات للخارج وقيود على
حريه التعبير
فبينما تحرم السلطات الكوريه الشماليه
المواطنين العاديين من الحق في الوصول الى
شبكات التواصل والانترنت الذي يخضع لرقابه
شديده لجانب حرمانهم من الحصول على كتب
وافلام اجنبيه ويتعرض من تضبط معه لعقوبات
مشدده توفره بسخاء لاخرين ولكن بشروط
تقديم صوره ورديه للحياه اليوميه
عبر منصات تواصل والاداء هنا الشباب
والاطفال روان حمزه العربيه
النشره انتهت مشاهدينا تشاهدون بعد قليل
وثائقي اثار الفراشه تكريما لذكرى الطفل
ريان يعود الى مسقط راس الطفل ويكشف
المزيد من التفاصيل لنشاهد جميعا
[موسيقى]